[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sera le meilleur francis lalanne ce
soir on va jamais malade c'est parti
eux nous suivre
à givry murat
eux qui me tient
max alan attention c'est parti hashtags
[Applaudissements]
tu
[Musique]
raymond lalanne
[Applaudissements]
tu brises
qui me tient
[Musique]
bon
comme noté
moi
[Musique]
alors qu'al honte à ses premières amours
[Applaudissements]
vivre à deux
[Musique]
m
au coeur de ce tunnel
je ne sais pas
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
promets moi si tu me survit d'être fort
fort que jamais je serai toujours dans
ta vie devrait de toi je te promets tu
me livre à une mise
un thème qui viennent
de tte brassard à moi comme je t'ai rien
mais nous vous c'est quoi
même paré chrysanthèmes du verre
on se retrouvera
non
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]